un giron part dans les tables 24 heures
sur 24 365 jours par an ce robot est au
service d'une centaine de prim'holstein
janvier et normandes ici les vaches donc
elles sont totalement libres elle mange
quand elles veulent et puis voilà quand
elles ont envie d'aller se faire faire
elles vont robot automatique ensuite
c'est pareil elles ont des logettes pour
se coucher quand elles veulent donc à
peu près 13 heures par jour et
ça
ça permet d'être au top au niveau
bien-être des animaux
dans la famille maurice c'est antoine
qui a la responsabilité de la production
laitière
après un bac scientifique il ne serait
jamais revenu à la ferme aider sa mère
viviane si la robotisation n'avait pas
été enclenchée ne voyait pas à 50 ans
comme mes parents et des anglais tente
ne plus avoir des pôles parce que la
traite c'était trop dur etc
c'est vrai que la qualité de vie
aujourd'hui c'est soucier primordial
dans les muqueuses
connecté au collier des bêtes ce robot
de traite est capable de détecter les
pics grâce à des capteurs de mesure et
le lait récoltés et de connaître l'état
de santé instantanément de la vache
c'est android développé par les
hollandais a coûté 100 mille euros le
prix pour apprécier son quotidien
la pénibilité
les bras qui commence vraiment à
fatiguer une corde qui fatigue et puis
le temps que l'on y passe là on passe
autant de temps mais avec une certaine
liberté tout de même
quand on a goûté à ça non latins si
enfin dimanche matin surtout un va peu à
peu la fête le samedi
benbouzid les huit heures dîner à 7h
lignes à 9 heures les robots ont fait
leur boulot un bon vous êtes là pour
fignoler mais non rien au monde non
[Musique]
la robotisation mois pour moi oui c'est
la nuit ceux qui en ont peur c'est
peut-être ce qui appréhende de s'en
servir pas de la voir mais de s'en
servir
fini donc la traite deux fois par jour
antoine 16e générations d'éleveurs chez
les morris a désormais du temps précieux
pour s'occuper et choyer ses buts
la robotisation de les tables est
intervenue cinq ans après le lancement
de la transformation du produit de base
le lait
un petit peu à la première fois c'était
pas encore aujourd'hui ça de plus en
plus aisément se lance mais à l'époque
on n'était pas vraiment dans l'air du
temps et pourtant c'est là qu'il fallait
commencer on est bien rendu compte après
par la suite le timing était parfait en
réalisant la transformation sur son but
d'exploitation la famille sur une grande
partie de ses revenus
la production de lait seule ne suffisait
plus pour vivre grâce à cette
robotisation le rendement est devenu
semi-industrielle 4 millions de pots à
l'année la moitié du lait récoltés et
transformés sur place et une dizaine
d'emplois a même dû être créé pour
suivre la cadence
oui on serait parvenu sur la perle et
aujourd'hui les parents très tous les
deux
a nui brignon celle et maurice les
robots ou tout simplement sauvé
l'exploitation